alright i think i'm just going to start
off first of all welcome everybody this
is the second of three primers for the
UIC I annual conference this conference
is going to take place on april 9th at
the law school here dl all the
information can be found here and if you
haven't yet please register today's
conference from is going to address the
topic of the conference technological
innovation for an energy secure future
and we're going to have three PhD
experts from Yale to speak on batteries
solar fuels and genomics and giving you
a short introduction to each of these
topics the speakers are called baby from
environmental engineering he's a third
year in drone patches lab we have forced
good Wilson he is a second year in
Android haila slab and he's in chemical
engineering and then the third person
speaking is going to be James Blake more
he's a fourth-year student in chemistry
and the ways of going to work is that
each of them is going to give you 15 10
15 minute introduction to the topic and
afterwards they're going to sit down and
discuss the feasibility of the
technology and the future of the
technologies together with gary moore
who is also a postdoc and Gary Boyd Vic
slip mat so thanks for coming out this
evening I'm forced gitelson from and
retailers lab just across the street
so if you're interested more and what I
say and in the discussion please come
and talk to us over there but my goal
today is just to introduce you to
battery technology specifically
rechargeable battery technology and
recent developments in the past few
years so why really do we need to be
interested in energy storage well if you
look at many of the main energy sources
or just energy sources that are being
considered for the future you'll notice
that several of the greenest ones have
the problem Oh only producing energy
intermittently for instance PV solar
cells or wind for other sorts of energy
sources like combustion and say a fuel
cell for the future these really don't
have a problem with portability but PV
solar cells yeah there's a problem with
portability and also for wind so for
these reasons we really need energy
storage and probably the if not the
easiest way definitely the most popular
way of storing energy is a battery so
you may recognize that there's some some
new cars coming out for instance the
chevy volt which use these sorts of new
batteries specifically lithium-ion and
then there's also Tesla roadsters so
these are actually quite applicable to
technology that's coming out recently
and in the very near future so before we
continue I think it's important to just
summarize several metrics of battery
evaluation and the most important is
definitely energy and gravimetric energy
volumetric energy that's when you
normalized by say the weight of the
battery or by the volume of the battery
in capacity is directly related to
energy so i'll be talking about that
also important is the power that you get
out of the battery for certain
applications you want high power for
some you want only like a trickle
current durability is also important for
saying your portable devices you don't
want them to last only a couple of
months you want to let them to last like
several years preferably for like
laptops you don't have to buy a new one
every year that would be great also
safety you don't want your batteries to
explode like some sony batteries did on
airplanes that's not a good idea also
you want to be able to recycle we're at
least dispose of some of these battery
materials in a green clean way so here's
some just general types of secondary
batteries I'm just going to be talking
about secondary batteries because this
is where most of the recent work is
being done you'll recall that lead acid
that's the typical battery that's used
in
your car it's very large bulky doesn't
have a great power density or energy
density then nickel cadmium and nickel
metal hydride we're kind of mainly used
in the 90s for portable devices like
cameras those are now if not obsolete
getting there and then there's less EMI
on which is the state of the art at the
moment and the reason that is the case
is seen on the graph on the right if I
had a pointer which I don't you see this
okay so this area is lithium ion and
that really also contains lithium
polymer and what is denoted as lithium
phosphate I guess yeah oh great perfect
okay so this area that's lithium polymer
so you can see that the energy density
is much better both gravimetric energy
density on this axis and volumetric
energy density on that axis meaning that
lithium ion batteries are both lighter
and smaller than competing technologies
they also operated higher voltages which
are good which is good for some
applications that require that they also
have very low rate of self discharge and
essentially have no memory effect so you
can charge them to whatever I don't know
fifty percent and then discharge and
there's no effect on the capacity
afterwards so it's important to just
realize how lithium ion batteries work
so a basic lithium ion battery is one
that is composed of a cathode and anode
with an electrolyte in the middle you
can see there's a separator because you
want to make sure that the anode and
cathode don't touch because that would
be a short circuit so you have to have
some sort of separator but the
electrolyte enables ions in this case
lithium ions
back and forth so in the charge
mechanism what you have is the
application of a voltage in which causes
lithium ions to transfer from the
cathode material a standard cathode
material is lithium cobalt oxide also
here's the reaction for the cathode and
with this application of the voltage
electrons go around the circuit to the
anode and lithium ions move across the
electrolyte to anode and bind there and
this is the anode reaction for the
discharge mechanism you essentially just
have the reverse lithium ions go back
across electrons go back around and that
is where you get your powering of your
device so as I said lithium cobalt oxide
is the standard cathode material at the
moment and that's because it has a
pretty decent capacity which is measured
in in this case and milliamp hours per
gram of 160 the difficulty or the
problem with this material is that using
cobalt is well let's just say it's not
renewable because there's a limited
amount of cobalt and it's actually kind
of expensive so we want to transition to
something that's cheaper and there's
more of so that's where these materials
come in these are different types of
crystals lithium manganese oxide and
lithium iron phosphate so lithium
manganese oxide was the first one of
these cathode materials to be developed
as an alternative to lithium cobalt
oxide but you can see that it has a
lower theoretical capacity than the
cobalt oxide material the reason why
it's used is because it's less expensive
which I guess makes sense and then
there's lithium iron phosphate which is
even more new than that which has a
superior capacity but suffers from
problems of poor electrical conductivity
which have been addressed by coating
some of those small particles of that
crystal with carbon or doping with other
sorts of transition metals that's where
this lithium blends comes in these are
the types of metals that might be used
to dope these crystals and improve
conductivity electrical conductivity and
durability and then there's also
vanadium pentoxide which is even newer
than that and not something that's
actually been considered too much so far
so it's really more of an up-and-coming
material for cathode and the problems
with that of course which need to be
addressed our poor electrical and ion
conductivity but you can see that the
capacity is superior so it's something
to be looked into on the anode side
graphite is the standard material and
that's because it is inexpensive and
it's light so it has a pretty decent
capacity and you'll notice that this
number is actually larger than for the
cathode material so that means that the
cathode is the limiting factor really
and all of these batteries but it's
important to improve the anode also be
trying to decrease the overall weight of
the battery so that's where these new
materials come in as long as an
alternative to graphite there are carbon
nanotubes single wall and multiwall
nanotubes some of them in some cases
because of the stoichiometry these offer
better capacities but are definitely
more expensive so that's something to be
addressed and maybe that means that it
doesn't these are not of great use
in commercial battery but they're
interesting for research purposes anyway
then there's also lithium alloying
materials like tin and germanium which
have better capacities but suffer from
problems mainly upon lithium
intercalation as diffusing of the
lithium ions into these materials when
you charge the these materials tend to
swell and also for this silicon and when
they swell they actually increase in
volume about three hundred percent and
then when you take the lithium ions out
they shrink and crack as in this picture
and that leads to a decrease in
electrical conductivity which is
something that really has to be
addressed so these these materials offer
great promise but specifically the
silicon nanowires are probably the state
of the art and anode materials now
because they address this cracking
feature because when the the increase in
volume occurs with lithium intercalation
what you see in this picture the that
expansion is actually kind of contained
in the axial direction or in the radial
direction there is a transition from you
know this morphology down here to the
amorphous morphology but for the most
part it's a pretty durable material and
silicon is light and relatively
inexpensive so and it has very good
capacity so that's definitely something
that's being considered and it's
actually well potentially will be used
in GM cars in the future and then
there's the electrolyte which is
probably one of the biggest challenges a
standard electrolyte is a liquid
electrolyte and most of the batteries
that you will see in portable devices
for instance and that's essentially just
lithium salt dissolved in an organic
solvent and because it's liquid the
lithium ions transfer pretty easily has
very good ion conductivity for that
reason but over the cycling there's a
lot of degradation that is the organic
solvent becomes for forms crystals which
then can cause a short circuit or
destroy the electrodes on both sides so
that's something that has been taken
care of in the typical lithium cobalt
oxide cell with with graphite but is
something that really hasn't been
considered in some of these new
materials as an alternative to a liquid
electrolyte you also have a polymer
electrolyte which could be a gel which
is essentially polymer and liquid
electrolyte together or mixed which also
acts as a separator so you don't need a
poor separator between your electrodes
so these types of cells are generally
thinner because you can coat them that
polymer electrolyte and separator pretty
thinly and that leads to flexible cells
which is good it's also lightweight
because it doesn't require extensive or
very heavy metal packaging as in other
sorts of well cells with liquid
electrolytes for instance it's also
better because you don't have the sorts
of electrolyte degradation that you do
with a like liquid electrolyte but
there's also increased internal
resistance which is something that can
be improved
I don't know either by heating for
instance because polymers usually or at
least the polymers being used in these
circumstances usually improve an ion
conductivity when you heat them or by
just developing new polymers that are
more ionically conductive and then also
for a different sort of electrolyte
there's glass ceramic electrolytes which
definitely require high temperature
operate operation in order to achieve
the ion conductivity that is typical for
at least anywhere near typical for a
liquid electrolyte but you do solve that
problem there's really no electrolyte
degradation but there's a bit of a
problem with getting good contact
between say a solid material and a solid
electrode also so lithium sulfur is a
bit of a new technology it's actually
not new it was introduced back or at
least hypothesized back in the 70s but
nobody really did anything with it until
recently and I'll explain to you why but
the reason why this is kind of an
interesting new perhaps next generation
lithium battery is because the
stoichiometry is pretty good you may
have seen I didn't actually point it out
but in some of the previous slides I did
show some strike geometries which have
Li for example c6 so that's one lithium
ion for every six carbons in this case
you have two lithium's for every one
sulfur so this is a favorable
stoichiometry when leads to a much
better theoretical capacity in any case
sulfur is also relatively inexpensive so
that's a benefit also the difficulties
in dealing with this sort of Technology
are mainly with degradation but also
since sulfur is
not electrically conductive you have to
deal with that by mixing it with say
some carbon or in a carbon matrix in
order to make it conductive so that ions
can flow away from the from the cathode
material the degradation for this sort
of material occurs in the intermediates
which formed between the most lithiated
compound and just the sulfur so these
materials actually dissolve an organic
electrolyte which means that you have a
large loss of material or active
material over time which is something
that has to be addressed and I this this
graph is just one example the paper that
this is from used a polymer electrolyte
in order to reduce the amount of organic
a liquid organic electrolyte in order to
control this and if you compared to some
of those theoretical capacities before
they were down here for standard
materials and now it's up here so that's
a good improvement and then you may have
also heard about lithium air or more
specifically lithium oxygen cells which
are quite similar to fuel cells in that
you don't have to the whole thing is not
enclosed so it so it's a flow sort of
system which involves lithium on one
side is the anode electrolyte in the
metal and a porous cathode on the other
side which is usually carbon plus some
sort of catalyst so what actually
happens is during discharge you have
lithium ions coming from the anode going
across the electoral electrolyte and D
compartment combining with oxygen which
flows through to form lithium oxide the
difficulty or the reason why this sort
of arc
lecture has only been considered
recently is because up until two
thousand nine nobody was really sure
that you could reverse these reactions
so now that you know you can at least
with certain catalysts like gold and
platinum those are of course expensive
but the benefit to this is in weight and
again favorable stoichiometry so from
this graph you can see this has all of
the previous rechargeable batteries and
I mentioned along with lithium ion
lithium sulfur the yellow represents
theoretical capacities so don't really
pay much attention to those but at least
the blues at least for the Blues you can
see that there's quite an improvement
over lithium ion in energy density with
lithium air and it even rivals gasoline
which is something good so I mentioned
all the good things about lifting mayor
of lithium oxygen and now these are all
the problems that we need to solve so we
need to improve catalysts in order to
improve the round trip efficiency so
this graph up here kind of gives you an
indication of what we're aiming for just
the plain old carbon you can see has a
difference or an over potential that's
pretty large between 2.5 volts and 4.5
volts when you add this novel catalyst
you reduce the overpotential and that
improves the round trip efficiency but
the best that has been able to be
achieved with these catalysts so far is
only sixty to seventy percent versus for
lithium ion it's about ninety-five
percent so that's something that has to
be addressed also in designing these
sorts of cells you have to make sure
that there's a pretty good air flow or
oxygen flow to the cathode and you have
to balance the the porosity of that
katha
versus the ion conductivity which is
from all of your eye on conducting
polymers that are in there also and then
you have to solve the problem of
electrolyte and membranes what do you
choose well that's a big question for
membranes you certainly need something
to block h2o because you can't have that
reacting with lithium that would be a
safety hazard and beyond that how are
you going to package this these are all
things that haven't really been
discussed so far in the literature and I
just wanted to leave you with an idea of
the research time frame and some of
these technologies that I've been
talking about back in nineteen ninety
one was when the first rechargeable
lithium-ion cell was produced by Sony
and you can see in this graph this is a
graph of publications over time
essentially there were no publications
on lithium ion at that point in time but
soon after that there was a large
increase and that corresponds with an
increase in commercial potential also
for those sorts of cells for lithium
sulfur and lithium-air we're down here
which means we're really nowhere near
actual commercial potential of these and
and I think probably for at least those
two technologies it's at least 15 years
out is what we're talking about so thank
you so um Kyle I work in Jordan Hatch's
lab in environmental engineering it with
Nina actually introduced everybody and
she asked me to give a talk today about
genomics in bio energy which is a huge
topic area so i decided to whittle it
down a little bit and talk about
something i know a little bit better a
subset of that which is next generation
DNA sequencing and apply that to bio
energy so the biological production of
energy or bioenergy
as enormous potential to replace fossil
fuels and reduce greenhouse gas
emissions which because you're here I'm
assuming you care about but it's we need
to figure out how to make the biology
work for us by that I mean Nature has
taken a billion plus years to evolve and
be really good at producing energy for
cells use within the cell but it has
never cared about producing energy for
us so we need to trick these cells or
trick these systems or design systems to
use this biology and produce energies
for us so some examples you might have
heard of anaerobic digestion very common
microalgae for fuel production or
biofuel grass like switchgrass or even
corn ethanol so knowledge of the
fundamental biology in these systems is
essential and critical we need to know
what's going on to design these systems
and maximize the energy output so some
really fundamental questions we might
ask is who's there if it's a mixed
community system and there's different
types of organisms or microorganisms
present we need to understand the
psychology this is a community
composition and who is doing what and
then in all the systems even for
switchgrass or any type of bioenergy
system we need to understand what are
these organisms doing and how are they
doing that to understand that we need to
know the genes and gene pathways
so there's multiple ways we could go
about trying to figure out these
fundamental biology questions one of
those possible ways is by using nucleic
acid sequencing or DNA sequencing so
just really quickly I don't know
everybody's background in the room but
when I talk about a nucleic acid or DNA
sequence each one of us has DNA all
organisms have DNA and they're comprised
of four nucleic acids and when I talk
about the sequence that's just the text
we use to represent this sequence so
once we get this sequence we can use
bioinformatics and other tools to
classify and characterize this sequence
and hopefully answer some of those
questions I was asking on the previous
slide and we're also lucky to be able to
use DNA to do this because it's very
unique and specific to genes and
functions so DNA sequencing has been
around for decades in some form it's
traditionally be called Sanger
sequencing but in 2005 what we call
next-generation DNA sequencing emerged
and this is really the enabling
technology here on this graph I have
both the speed and cost of DNA
sequencing graft cost is on the dashed
line and that's on the Left axis there
this is these are log axes and speed is
on the solid line and on the right axis
you could see it's gone down cost has
gone down significantly and speed has
gone up significantly in the last five
years and it continues to do so so this
means we're able to produce lots and
lots and lots of sequence data so this
is great for centuries biology was
limited by the amount of data it can
produce but right now is what we're in
the middle of what is commonly called
the data deluge right now we have more
data because of these technologies than
we even know what to do with it's great
because it allows us to produce
biological insights that we wouldn't be
able to produce otherwise
but we need rapidly evolving
bioinformatics and we need really
powerful computational tools to make
sense from the sequence so just as a
little bit of background if people talk
about genomics at the YC iconference
some next-generation sequencing
companies or platforms the second
generation which is in use right now is
called 454 or lumen of those are really
popular and emerging right now is called
the third generation which is even more
sequences at less cost and those are
produced by companies called PacBio or
ion torrent this is just a just a brief
example okay so what what specifically
can these technologies tell us so when
we talk about genomics I generally think
of genome sequencing and this is taking
a an organism's DNA and sequencing all
of it and this tells us the genetic
potential of an organism we can tell
what genes it has and what it could
potentially do with those jeans in the
pathways it can act there's also
metagenomics which is if you have a
mixed community or a community of
different types of organisms you
sequence all of their DNA and see
collectively what can they do and what
genes do they have this also tells you
the community composition or gets at the
question who is there and last of all
transcriptomics you sequence the RNA of
an organism and that shows you the genes
that are actually transcribed and then
more likely expressed so what does this
mean for bioenergy this is just little
bit of background on generate
next-generation sequencing in genomics
it means that we can discover genes and
gene pathways much more easily and
rapidly than we could even a few years
ago and we could rapidly characterize
these complex systems this is great
because it tells us how we need to
operate these bio energy systems to
maximize the bioenergy output and it
also lets us explore additional crazy
out there ideas really quickly and
cheaply and maybe one of them will be
the gold mine and another idea that is
enabled by this is bioprospecting which
is we take unknown organisms and we
sequence their DNA and see what genes
and pathways they express that maybe we
could utilize or genetically engineer
into another organism so that's just the
background on genomics right now I'm
going to get into a little bit of work
that our lab does on microalgae and
biofuel production as a kind of a case
study for what we what we actually do
with this technology so you might have
heard of micro algae biofuels before but
they accumulate high level of starches
and lipids which we can then use to
produce biodiesel or ethanol algae or
advantageous because they require less
land space than other biofuel crops and
they also don't compete with food crops
so because of that there's been a lot of
recent interest in this technology
unfortunately there's only two
microalgae lipid accumulating microalgae
with their complete genomes sequenced
and this is really limiting also
sequencing their complete genome is
still difficult and time-consuming so
our lab decided we're only interested in
the genes that these these microalgae
express so we're going to sequence
what's known as the transcriptome or the
mRNA of this microorganism and this
gives us more functional information and
tells us genes that are actually
expressed much more quickly and rapidly
than genome genome sequencing so this
was really successful so some pathways
that we care about because of fuel
production and for example of fatty acid
biosynthesis or tag biosynthesis we
found almost all of the enzymes that are
known to exist and those that weren't
found are likely because they don't have
a known home log in the database so
we're also limited by sequence
information is at and as we continue to
sequence and do this more and more will
be more and more successful at
identifying enzymes and identifying
genes and gene pathways so just as an
example pathway to show you what we can
uncover just from these string of four
letters this is the fatty acid
biosynthesis pathway pathway that we
uncovered and we were successful at
uncovering all the enzymes here and see
how it functions we're also using this
information can see how what level these
genes are expressed and see under
different conditions do gene our genes
expressed differently can we engineer
systems to produce more fatty acids for
use in biodiesel production if you're
interested in this the paper was just
published last week in BMC genomics so
with that I like to thank you for your
attention and also think how need and
brought who work on this work on algae
and aninha for planning this and my
advisor Jordan thanks I'm as Nina said
I'm James great horn and I'm from the
chemistry department and i'll be talking
to you about solar fuels which is a very
flashy name i think and so hopefully i
can provide some info to go with that
flash
okay so i'll be talking to you today
about solar fuels and i think before i
start i am my actual presentation i
would just mention where solar fuels
fits into sort of the overall picture of
alternative energy so the way i think
about it is is that currently a dominant
fraction of the global energy demand is
being met by unsustainable carbon-based
so-called fossil fuels and if you look
at the transportation sector in
particular you'll note that an even
higher proportion of the total fuel that
drives transportation is carbon based
and of course it's great you know you
put some reduced carbon like gasoline
into your car and as you drive you can
emit a colorless gas carbon dioxide so
your vehicle gets lighter and you know
there it's very easy to just go and fill
up again with more of that colorless
liquid but the premise of solar fuels is
to utilize energy from the Sun which is
arguably our best renewable sustainable
resource for energy for either the
direct or indirect production of fuel
like gasoline or hydrogen today i'll
talk a lot about hydrogen we want to
produce fuel rather than electricity or
heat precisely because we'll be very
useful for transportation for being
transported but in general the science
of producing solar fuels presents
serious challenges to chemists chemical
engineers and companies who are working
to demonstrate and better understand
just the basic science and the basic
processes that will
necessary for accomplishing the
chemistry but it's really a great
opportunity and a wonderful challenge as
a chemist to be confronted with all
these problems and all hopefully in my
presentation I'll be able to show you
the background and then also some of the
things that we're doing here at Yale in
our group so just as Kyle talked about
biology we also are looking to nature
not as directly as bioenergy people but
more for inspiration and in many ways
natural photosynthetic machinery in
plants and bacteria provides a blueprint
for methods to successfully capture
convert and store solar energy oxygen is
all around us and it has been being
produced by plants green plants and sign
of bacteria and other organisms for
about 24 hundred million years on the
planet so as Klaus said all these
machinery are very well tuned to
transduce energy from sunlight and to
fix carbon from the air and of course
it's the carbon that plants fix fossil
fuels that we're now burning over those
2,400 years but plants a symbol
elaborate photo systems which capture
solar energy and use that energy to take
electrons from their environment from
water and to reduce carbon dioxide to to
fuel and they do it in as I said a very
efficient manner so without I'll try not
to rely on too many equations as a
chemist but plants take six carbon
dioxide's and six waters and they add in
some light and then we were get sugar
out as I've written here and oxygen if
we want to break down that process into
its simplest components
then on the oxidation side plants are
taking water like we drink and with
light they pull electrons out of water
to release oxygen and protons those
electrons and protons are then used by
other pieces of cellular machinery to
reduce carbon dioxide to a reduced form
of carbon and that reduced carbon is
fuel and the chemistry of the water
oxidation site in particular is very
specific and it's only been accomplished
by plants using one enzymatic system one
oxygen-evolving complex and so all of
the plants from the sleeping giant State
Park to the mountains of Switzerland to
the you know wheat fields of Kansas all
the electrons that those plants are
using to fix carbon dioxide is coming
through one molecular catalyst one
manganese complex oh we see here so our
plants doing this this there is a light
absorbing cofactor labeled p680 which
absorbs light from the Sun visible light
and chemical events cause electrons to
be passed out of that cofactor and the
electrons to replace those ones that are
being kicked out by the light come from
water and for electrons and for protons
are pulled out of water and oxygen is
released so plants are using light to
drive these key endothermic reactions
which means that their energy demanding
they don't happen spontaneously and as I
as is written here the first of these
reactions occurs in an enzyme called
photosystem 2 which oxidizes water to
dioxygen
which is amazing for many reasons one of
which is that water is one of the most
difficult to oxidize substances and in
fact the entire protein framework that
surrounds all of these cofactors is
easier to oxidize in an absolute sense
than water but the chemistry is tuned
exactly at that oxygen-evolving complex
which is you may have noticed is what
one of my labs research directions is
that its center is tuned to oxidize
water exactly plants do this rapidly
approximately 40 per second 40 oxygens
or produced per second the plants do
this with very little wasted energy
they're very efficient harnessing that
solar light to do the chemistry and then
importantly in something we may read a
lot about in the solar fuels literature
is that plants accomplish this with
abundant and what we would call cheap
materials so things like the noble
metals platinum iridium are not used by
plants it's manganese which we've
already heard is cheap and widely
available
so just to to clarify again the light
driven water oxidation is great and it's
the ultimate source of the electrons or
protons use for these other biological
processes and as those protons and
electrons that are used to produce NADPH
which then is fed into the Calvin Benson
cycle for reducing carbon dioxide to
sugars and lipids and things like that
so all these rack reactions are very
difficult to accomplish its take in
plants billions of years to tune them
and so chemists are faced with this very
large challenge of mimicking these
difficult reactions in simple artificial
synthetic model systems so how can we do
the chemistry of water oxidation or co2
reduction in a test tube the chemical
steps of all of these reactions have
kinetic barriers so not to get too
technical but every process has some
thermodynamic minimum of energy that's
required to accomplish it and then
there's some additional energy which
comes from reorganizing the matter to
accomplish that reaction and to lower
those kinetic barriers those
reorganization energy barriers we need
better catalysts for the reactions that
we're trying to drive with light and
unfortunately they're the way it is is
that the thermodynamics of these
reactions are set it will always take
energy to split water into oxygen and
protons and will always take some energy
however little to turn protons or
protons and co2 into some sort of a
reduced fuel but we can organize things
in such a way to minimize the kinetic
barriers and produce fuel efficiently so
we can think of many approaches for
doing solar energy conversion in plants
we have co2 going to sugars using
electrons that come from water being
going to oxygen and if we want to mimic
that sort of chemistry there are many
many different types of ways we can
mimic it photovoltaic devices absorb
energy and do charge separation which
gives you electrons traveling in a loop
around a circuit where they's the light
energy that excites those electrons is
used then to accomplish electrical work
we can also think about building
electrochemical or photoelectrochemical
devices which is the center column which
is semi conductor liquid Junction cells
and so in a cell like this you may be
familiar in high school you may have
taken a battery put wires on the two
leads put it into water and seen bubbles
coming out from both sides oxygen on one
hydrogen on the other so that is in a
nutshell when I think of solar fuels is
a paradigm and that we are going to
provide some energy to a beaker of water
essentially and we'll get oxygen out as
a side product and then hydrogen that
will harness or hydrogen equivalent as
fuel which is essentially what's shown
in the middle in the in one scheme for
artificial photosynthesis to give solar
fuels light energy is directly coupled
to the chemistry of producing fuel so
that we would essentially shine light on
a device and from that device we would
get transportation fuel something that
we could bottle put in our car drive
away so let's see so there are there's
so if we burn hydrogen all we're going
to get back out is water so it's a
closed-loop carbon neutral if we pull
co2 from the air and reduce that and
then burn it once again there's no net
co2 release so we're not no longer
pulling carbon out of the ground
and burning it we're just doing some
sort of cyclic carbon neutral process so
there are I that's sort of the main
background and now I will share some
vignettes of the community I guess so
this is one slide so you'll notice my
last slide came from Nate Lewis who is
one of the guests that will be coming to
the actual annual conference in a few
weeks and he's heading a large
initiative they'll tell you about in a
few minutes but this slide comes from
the National Renewable Energy Lab and
John Turner and essentially what what
this slide says is that there are many
sustainable paths to hydrogen you can do
some sort of a thermal process where
water is heated with special material
giving hydrogen from the heat of solar
energy you can get mechanical energy in
the form of wind or waves to get
electricity and then do a basic water
electrolysis project process to get
hydrogen you can do a biomass process
where plants harvest light fixed carbon
and then through some sort of conversion
process can give hydrogen and then also
Fatah lassus routes where the light
absorption is directly coupled to
production of fuel so just to reiterate
an electrolyzer which all we'll see more
of in a minute a water electrolyzer is
an energy conversion device which
converts electrical or photo photo
energy directly into chemical energy in
the form of chemical bonds bonds are in
in your fuel in your car so you burn the
fuel get co2 out what not but
essentially here is your high school
electrolysis experiment where you've put
energy into a beaker of water and on one
side you produce hydrogen on the other
oxygen but as you can imagine refining
that process to minimize the kinetic
barriers that I mentioned before is
quite a complex
a complex and demanding game so in this
cell there's one side where we take
water to oxygen and then protons move
across either a membrane or a diaphragm
it was listed here or just across your
beaker of water and you get hydrogen out
and it's an endothermic reaction and as
I've drawn it here we're applying an
electrical voltage which convert the
water into hydrogen but in a direct
approach the blue material which is
unlabeled here would be both a catalyst
for water oxidation and also a
light-absorbing unit which directly
transfers light energy to a catalyst to
drive fuel production so here at Yale as
I mentioned I work in the chemistry
department I personally have two
advisors both of whom are listed here
Gary britvic and Bob Crabtree but at
Yale there is a green energy consortium
as we call it in which for chemistry p
is work to use solar light for fuel
production we have Victor Batista one of
whom students I see here who's a
computational chemist so we use modeling
approaches to study the reactions we
wish to carry out in a computer before
we build them or after Gary bread vig
has a background in studying the natural
system for photosynthesis and also in
modeling that chemistry with artificial
catalysts Bob Crabtree is an inorganic
chemist who also studies catalysis and
then finally Charlie schmuck Meyer is a
ultra-fast spectroscopy who uses the
interaction of matter with light to get
important information about these
chemistry
as a chemist what we do is we look at I
personally just a vignette of my work is
to look at catalyst switch accomplish
the transformation of converting water
to oxygen with a low barrier you'll
notice that i personally use iridium
which is not an abundant material but
we're learning a lot about the chemistry
it's another catalyst so this is another
piece of the puzzle that we will see at
the annual conference in the solar fuels
section one of the industrial panelists
is Rob Friedlander who's the CEO of a
company called proton energy systems
proton energy systems is a actually a
Connecticut company just up the road in
wallingford which manufactures some of
though what I would consider the world's
best water electrolyzers and so in this
movie which I took water is going into
the cell through the white port on the
back and the white port on the front is
water than carrying away oxygen that's
the product of water electrolysis and
the tube on the top which is going up
that is hydrogen gas that's produced so
the reaction that's written on the
bottom is what you're seeing as part of
the student Congress's recent mini
conference or symposium the VP of
research of proton energy systems came
and gave a talk all about their
technology and one of the pieces that
she mentioned is is that right now there
really is no market or no no feasible
market for using their devices to
produce fuel in a cost-competitive
fashion either with electricity from
coal or electricity from solar panels so
one thing to watch out for would be to
hear Rob Friedlander's feelings about
the prospects for their type of water
electrolysis which is proton exchange
membrane water electrolysis for fuel
production and also how it may fit into
the whole
grander solar fuels vision another piece
is the so called solar fuels hub which
is based in or will be based in
California it's more formally called or
will be called the Joint Center for
artificial photosynthesis and Nate Lewis
another guest of the annual conference
solar fuels section who's giving the
keynote I believe our keynote is the
head of Jacob and he'll I'm sure share
lots of details about their proposed
work but from their website I was just
looking at it today the mission of j cap
is to demonstrate a scalable and
cost-effective solar fuels generator
that without the use of rare materials
or wires robustly produces fuel from the
sun 10 times more efficiently than
typical current crops so imagine that in
the multi year time frame of their
institute they will produce a box which
when rolled out into sunlight will
produce hydrogen or reduced carbon it's
incredible but today I can tell you the
technology isn't there another final
piece and something that we're
affiliated with here at Yale is across
the nation there are many are several
inert water so-called energy frontier
research centers which are funded by the
Department of Energy as is j cap this is
the one that I'm most familiar with
because this is the center that I work
for but they aim to do all of the things
that I've just described for you
efficient catalysis light absorption and
coupling all of these myriads processes
together to efficiently convert abundant
materials into fuel and just to close i
thought i would show one thing that just
came out in the literature this week
from this institute so this is an
article from the journal of the american
chemical society the references is on
the materials that i turned
to the planners but the title is
biomimetic multifunctional porous
schalke Gauss's solar fuel catalysts
which is very exciting and scientific
but essentially to boil it down for the
fur or not for non-experts essentially
these researchers have prepared a
membrane of sorts which is stable under
the desired conditions and when light is
shone on the membrane under certain
conditions which are carefully chosen to
demonstrate the technology this membrane
produces hydrogen so this is in one area
where we are today the interface of
nanotechnology and chemistry and
engineering and of course I'm sure all
of your and I are looking forward to the
annual conference where we'll hear more
of the details of these individual
approaches to solving this very
difficult problem so thank you so we'll
have the panelists sit down at the table
and garen muer will help ask informed
questions and then lead up to the
audience as well all right let's start
with a warm welcome for our speakers
today we had the opportunity to hear
three talks of what is essentially yells
response to the incoming energy crisis
or what's been called the energy
challenge or by some that the terawatt
challenge and it really addresses the
scale of this issue currently is a as a
planet we operated a burn rate of thirty
terawatts so that's energy per unit time
you'll have to worry about per year or
per day and that number is predicted to
move from this current 15 terawatts to
30 terawatts and neglect by coming 2050
and so this is a serious issue of how do
we meet this demand for global human
energy consumption as we heard from some
of our speakers today solar provides a
resource it's abundant and 120,000
terawatts but it's rather diffuse
and intermittent and I think one of the
things that came through and the talks
were here today is the issue of storage
how do we store energy and so we hear it
talks about battery technologies and
advancements in air lithium and we also
heard about the approach of using
nature's technique of storing storing
energy and fuels whether that be by
artificial photosynthesis or
manipulation of existing organisms so
we'll take questions at this point but
as the moderator I have the privilege of
being able to ask the first question and
so I'll ask our speakers what are in
your own opinions the Grand Challenges
within the individual approaches that
each of you addressed and moving this
technology forward and maybe if we start
with reverse order will start with James
and move towards me well I I think I
alluded to it in my presentation but and
of course you're very familiar with this
but I think coupling all of these
chemical processes needed to produce
solar fuels directly coupling all of the
chemistry required multi-electron
chemistry's we call it with single
photon light absorption but also kind of
this the scale of the problem nano to
macro so that I would say that the
coupling of the various disparate
chemical pieces together needed to
produce the fuel
I think I talked about it as well in the
beginning of my talk like I said Nature
has gotten really good at generating
energy for itself or for an organism to
generate energy for itself in just in
the last several decades we've had this
idea we're going to use these processes
to generate energy for us so I think the
big the big challenge is first to figure
out how we're going to do that and do it
cheaply and cost competitively with
fossil fuels and engineer that and
secondly is to kind of survey all of the
available possibilities and bioenergy
bioenergy production which there are way
more than we've even begun to think
about looking at it yet and make sure
that we've covered our bases there so
more of a high-throughput approach to
bioenergy for energy storage I think
probably the major challenge is an
economic one it's designing materials or
at least developing materials that are
better but still are less expensive or
at least as expensive as current
materials because you could essentially
just make any you could come up with
something very exotic using exotic
elements but eventually if the rare
elements it's going to be expensive and
then there's really no point in actually
applying it to anything so once you find
those materials though the next
challenge is actually making them into
something that works appropriately and
that's done using variety of say
synthesis methods and then beyond that
really have to use engineering in order
to put it together in a package where
it's actually going to be something
that's used
which and end safe and safety is a big
issue at least for energy storage
portable energy storage that is thank
you it it seems that most of you
addressed a science issues as ones being
the grand challenges but presumably
there's also policy issues could you
share with us some some policy issues so
for biofuels enlarged not all bioenergy
but for biofuels we talked about even
algae which don't directly compete with
food crops they're likely to require
some sort of fertilizer and they're
definitely going to require water so I
think there are some ethical and policy
concerns with biofuel production and
competing with food crops and driving up
food prices and land land use challenges
so I think in terms of policy and
ethical concerns that's the biggest
there so for energy storage and for
portable batteries at least as I said
that the thrust is really on the
consumer side rather than the policy
side but policy would come into play in
say funding of these sorts of projects I
know that the Department of Energy has a
big initiative to develop batteries for
vehicles that are up to certain
standards but they're not only funding
academic research the funding commercial
research so it really has to do I mean
in that sense policy is important and
then
I guess policy would also be important
in terms of say using the natural
resources that it takes to get the
materials that is not strip mining in
order to get certain rare materials not
disposing of hazardous lithium in
improper ways but beyond that it's it's
not that big of a policy issue I don't
think so i think i'll take short-term
and long-term policy issues as a
scientist you hear this a lot in the
community and it becomes readily
apparent after working in a laboratory
setting that really what we need in
terms of development of you know better
chemistry and you know solar fuels
technology is not bursts of funding but
sustained solid support in terms of
grants and the sort of the direction of
those grants towards the goals these
problems cannot be solved quickly is
what i would say and what we need is
collaborative efforts sustained over the
year time scale not the decade time
scale not the political cycle but then
so the longer term once we have the
support to develop the technology i
would say that what we need is in terms
of policy is just constant debate and
discussion about how to move from the
existing energy system which is so
reliant on carbon to a new energy system
and of course
I'd like to think that one day we will
be absolutely carbon neutral on on solar
fuels but I know that it's going to take
decades to get there I realized i missed
something so a problem probably a lot of
you listen to the State of the Union and
there's a big initiative to increase the
number of electric vehicles on the road
by 2020 yeah so my editorial on that is
that it's not actually possible without
somebody wanting to buy those cars so
you can put in all of the funding that
you want but you won't necessarily get
to the point where you're increasing the
the use of that technology in accordance
with whatever the policy decisions are
so yeah so I have a number of questions
I can keep asking but I'll open it up to
the floor to take some questions and
maybe interject from from time to time
their questions in the audience so far
speakers Harold a pharmacist how do you
recognize how do you reconcile going
from carbon to inorganic energy sources
with our ability to go to space and with
space being so disruptive disruptive and
since space is primarily the things in
space is part our primary primarily
inorganic how would you would you see
for see the progress from going from a
carbon 22 in organic source like
hydrogen
I assume this is a solar fuels issue so
I guess I i sidestepped the issue during
my talk but the simplest case in terms
of thinking about an electrochemical
cell is to think about splitting water
as they say into oxygen and using the
hydrogen directly as a fuel but there
are other possible schemes where carbon
in some form is incorporated into a
reduced fuel using the electrons and
protons to come from from water so I
think it's totally possible and likely
that technology will be developed which
takes some sort of a carbon feedstock be
it co2 or something else which is then
reduced into fuel in the manner that we
think of it today which of course solves
a lot of problems because hydrogen is a
very light flammable diffuse gas whereas
gasoline is a nice compact liquid which
can be easily pumped into your gas tank
so there are many approaches and I think
that traditional carbon-based fuels that
we make ourselves shouldn't be
discounted
like in Texas you have you have big
interest in and the windmills is there
Ithaca lean-to or alternative energy so
that one like 11 is favored over the
other for a better ethical reason such
as windmills favorite over hydrogen or I
think the issue there is hydrogen I
guess would be more of a storage form
whereas wind is a capture and conversion
technology so you're capturing wind
energy but you still have the same
storage issues with for example your
question of wind versus versus hydrogen
and one thing that I hope came across
during my presentation at least is that
when we talk about renewable energy it
seems more and more that what we talk
about is a bookshelf or a small set or a
growing set of distinct and different
solutions which at least for the short
term sort of form a a family of related
technologies that are growing and form
sort of a suite of solutions to the
energy problem which one wins seems less
important in terms of implementation we
heard that will take years decades maybe
to implement either of these
technologies is there one technology
that will be favored over others or is
more likely to quicker succeed and be
implemented you have any ideas on that
the typical answer by scientists is the
one I'm working on
and we're all scientists so watch out so
so for biofuels there's lots of for
bioenergy there's lots of competing
options so for example anaerobic
digestion is commonly used all over the
country right now maybe it's not
optimized but it's used and then there's
things like algae biofuels and other
types of biofuels that we might use that
aren't really used right now but could
be used pretty quickly because we're
making a substance if you make biodiesel
that we can put into a trucks gas tank
right now so that timeline could be
quick but it probably won't be and then
there's other further off ideas in
bioenergy that are probably on the
decade timescale so it's a very broad
area for that specific for bioenergy
that goes from in use today two decades
decades off for energy storage I think
probably there's no one or the other
there's it's not you know alternatives
there's just optimization so essentially
you you start with something and then
you find something that's slightly
better and you run with it so that's
been kind of the course of how secondary
batteries have been developed over the
years and I mean in this is where some
of the research is going first two easy
things and I'm like lithium sulfur from
just typical with EMI on or
and then eventually to harder things
like lithium-air and you know
potentially coupling batteries to fuel
cells sauce if a recent paper which is
actually quite interesting that couples
the the idea of lithium air with the
fuel cell and actually I mean it's very
complicated and would require quite a
lot of engineering to actually make
something that's usable but if it was
gotten to the point where it could work
in commercially anyway then I think it
would probably become the new standard
so in the in the area of solar fuels and
hydrogen what I would say is that the
technology exists to produce hydrogen
with a photovoltaic at least and then to
put that hydrogen into a bottle and to
put the hydrogen in that bottle into
your into a fuel cell car the problem of
course is is that it's extremely
expensive hydrogen produced by water
electrolysis in a study from the early
2000s in England at least was that
hydrogen produced from electrolysis of
water is four times as expensive as
hydrogen produced by other means from
fossil fuel but they're encouraging
developments I'm sure Rob Friedlander
will share that proton energy in a
related company Sun hydro have an
initiative to create an East Coast
hydrogen Highway the first station or
fueling station on that highway is now
open in wallingford and it uses proton
energies water electrolysis technology
to produce hydrogen for a small fleet of
belief Toyota or GM fuel cell cars
so I think I think we're seeing a lot of
development but as I said I think we
need sustained interests and policy
support
so for the two gentlemen I'm aside
probably more than the storage in the
work that you're doing how do you
foresee scalability to commercial levels
well III guess i can start so in the
work that i personally do i study one of
the catalytic transformations and that's
the transformation of water into oxygen
and I don't use light directly in my own
work to accomplish that transformation I
use electricity so I essentially study
water electrolysis and the catalysts
that I use for that reaction is iridium
an iridium is among the least abundant
metals on the planet it's a noble metal
a transition metal so I don't think that
any of us will have an Iridium based
water electrolyzer in our basements
anytime soon but I do think that
studying such non-commercial Liza bowl
or less commercialised bowl systems is
still of interest and I think we're
still learning a lot there's a lot of
work going on now to search for
catalysts that are based on abundant
metals and I think that well I know that
based on you know work that's come out
just in the past two or three years
since I've been a graduate student that
we can expect great things
I don't think they're oh I don't think
they're open yet oh yes yeah yeah I
think seven to ten
so you know the policy issue and
production and the long-term use of this
technology say they will be already been
you know somehow talked about the
environment but even more direct is the
development of this technology and also
this technology as it has been said you
know we're going to use more newer
technology as it's available right so
some technology is going to become
obsolete right so I would like to know
the environmental impact in the
development of the this technology and
also the environmental impact of the
obsolete technology that is no longer
useful
yes I guess I can kind of address that
because okay well as you know it's
difficult to dispose of batteries in
general especially like primary ones and
ones that involve you know acids and you
have toxic things so right now that you
can't really get rid of them you can you
can take them apart and it has to be
done in a very controlled environment
and any if you were to dispose of say
lithium cells you'd have to do it in a
very careful way where it's safe and
actually I probably would be quite
expensive and that's actually something
that i think has been factored into the
development some of these new electric
cars that they're the batteries in them
are only supposed to last about five
yeah about ten years I think something
like eight to ten years and then what
are they going to do after there I think
many of the companies especially GM
which has the new vault and Tesla are
going to be taking those batteries back
in and we'll be disassembling them and
reusing whatever lithium is left and the
materials left over and put it in
recycling them assuming that that all
that material is still usable in the
next generation which if it isn't
there's you know huge loss there and
somehow if you don't use it again it has
to be disposed of and that's going to be
costly no matter what
I think it's a serious error we can
learn from nature and nature moves large
amounts of energy so we said a 120,000
terawatts of sunlight earlier and 30
terawatts of that is we would need as we
move to the future nature in the process
of photosynthesis does close close to 90
terawatts of turnover and and the way it
does this was avoiding a generation of
waste as cycles and you want to do
things in cycles you want to have things
where your end product is your starting
material and this is one of them's a
promising areas of the the solar fuels
is that you're using water you're
splitting that water and then you your
fuels bringing it back together to make
water so it's a closed cycle but it is
this is a serious issue of innovation
every every innovator has to look behind
them and we have this huge pile of trash
behind us you know that we've left in
our wake so can I I'd like to add one
thing so everyone's car that runs on
gasoline at least has a catalytic
converter in it and in that catalytic
converter there's precious metal rhodium
and rhodium is one of the most expensive
elements it's a transition metal but
it's recycled from those from all those
catalytic converters and reused likewise
in proton exchange membrane water
electrolyzers there are precious metal
catalysts inside and luckily first of
all it's not the catalyst that dies in
that device it's the plastic fittings
that connect everything together and the
proton exchange membrane itself but when
they were catalyst and the assembly does
go in for refurbishing the precious
metals can be recycled and reused from
within that membrane so if we do deploy
a fleet of these electrolysis cells with
precious metals there's some possibility
for recycling in that regard
maybe get one last question and final
statements so hydrogen and batteries are
both very relevant to transportation I
was wondering if you like your path
converting sunlight into hydrogen using
that in a fuel cell in a car versus
converting sunlight into electricity
using photovoltaic still storing in the
NIMH battery and then fueling a car
using that to propel a car what are the
Sun to wheel efficiencies of both paths
and well the winners stay the winner or
will it flip what Christian see well
Gary di please I'd oh I don't I don't
know the absolute efficiency off the top
of my head I know that there are serious
limitations both in terms of the like
you've--you so of you if we assume that
the light-absorbing efficiency is going
to be the same for the photovoltaics in
each case and we can throw that out as
the same limitation for each it's it's a
tricky question efficiency and it
depends how you define it hey okay so if
we define it as total energy in versus
total energy out photosynthetic
organisms biological organisms are
rather inefficient they operate at
efficiencies less than five percent so
we look at current photovoltaics that I
could go in a store and buy today they
operate at a energy conversion
efficiency of roughly fifteen to twenty
percent now mind you the solar electric
has done now solar to electricity
whereas photosynthesis has done solar to
fuel and you have something you can burn
at the end of the day it's stored but on
top of that as James point on his talk
you can buy commercial water
electrolyzers Andy's operate at very
high efficiency 75 to 80 percent
efficiency so many ways technology
already outcompetes biology in terms of
just efficiency and I think where the
real problem comes in though is one of
cost nature does these at relatively low
cost you
earth abundant materials that operate at
room temperature and in under very mild
conditions and so I think this is a
strategy that that human can learn from
and pushing our innovations and
technology forward is to bring the cost
down I guess I realized that the thing
is the difference is that there's one
more step for making a solar fuel I'm
because you still have to use the fuel
and then there's a loss of efficiency
there but I mean there will be beyond
just making the electricity and then
storing it has to be transferred
somewhere and that has to be through
some sort of wires and again their
losses there which may or may not be as
large I don't know exactly but if you
just go by the steps and the losses at
each step I guess it's I don't guess I
shouldn't probably say anything not
knowing the numbers but I'm biased so
yeah it's correct Navarro my
understanding the battery technology the
push for technology really has been in
improving energy densities and power
densities which which are subtly
different from your chart we sell today
is historically the battery technology
maybe somewhere around point five
kilograms or I'm sorry megawatts per
kilogram but with you some of these
lithium-air battery technology shows
they really are pushing upwards towards
fuels which we which are around 50
megawatts per kilogram for liquid fuels
hydrogen a little bit higher maybe maybe
150 closer to so I think it's a
different different questions to address
for different capture and conversion
versus storage
I think we reached the end of our time
for today but there will be a
continuation which will happen next
Wednesday the 30th and Kroon Hall where
actually the advisors of these beautiful
and wise folks will speak as well and
for the continued to talk about the
technology addressed that is going to be
also at 6pm and it's going to end around
seven-thirty so for now let's thank our
speakers one more time